[Music]
this is one of the most populous cities
in sub-saharan Africa more than 4
million people live here among them
eight-year-old Ida a coding wizard Emma
bet test by the manager of a big flower
farm and ass affirming Geshe a pioneer
in Ethiopia's solar power industry all
three illustrates how Africa's fortunes
might change in the coming decades the
continent faces many challenges
including the recent spread of kovat 19
but in the long term there is reason to
be optimistic by the end of this century
Africa is set to play a much bigger role
in world affairs the Asian growth
miracle is likely to slow Africa's rapid
rise could be next
[Music]
some 8 million natives whom the fights
still look upon in the words of Rudyard
Kipling as the new court sullen people's
half devil and half child for hundreds
of years Africa was dismissed by much of
the rest of the world today Africa is
too big to ignore
it's population is growing faster than
any other continent the UN predicts that
by 2100 one human being in three will be
African doomsayers worried about
overpopulation they fear that the number
of mouths will grow faster than the food
supply and people will starve but the
UN's population predictions may be wrong
if Africa continues to grow at the
expected rate its population will almost
double by 2050 to two and a half billion
people but in the second half of the
century forecasts diverge depending on
different rates of fertility the medium
rate which the UN expects implies the
population would almost double again by
2100 that forecast is based on the
belief that the number of children each
woman has were decline only slowly that
underestimates the impact of education
on girls like Ida my name is Ida I am 88
and a half years old my birthday is
coming and live India
at school either isn't a star student
she loves learning and so do many other
girls in Ethiopia primary school
enrolment rates for girls increased from
around 34 percent in 2000 to 81 percent
in 2015 we acted education has a strong
influence on fertility rates a woman
with no formal education will have six
or more children this full staff or if
she finished primary school and - about
- if she finished secondary school I
want to go like this first time in Katy
prep and then I go to grade one after 12
and then I go to high school and then I
go to college and then I go to
university
according to one study if the rate of
social development in particular the
education of girls doesn't change the
population of Africa will be as high as
the UN predicts but look what happens to
the population size if there's even a
median improvement and development and
if there is a rapid rise towards the end
of the century the population will
decline which means the more girls are
educated the lower Africa's population
is likely to be
I'm telling you that girls could do
anything they want everyone in Ethiopia
knows that girls could do whatever boys
could do which raise out car there
both Ida's grandmother and mother were
well-educated and have had successful
careers educated women are more likely
to enter the workforce
despite being half of Africa's
population women generated just 33
percent of the continents collective GDP
in 2018 if women enter the workforce at
the same rate as men Africa could add 10
percent to its GDP over the next five
years and it's not just what girls like
Ida learn in school that will affect
Africa's economic future but what they
learn outside school
Eider is learning to code how many sides
[Music]
my brother wanted to code efforts he
told our mom can we go to coding school
and then she said okay I'll sign it up
when we grow up we could be wonderful
coders we can teach more people to cook
goodness me with Olympus Ebola yeah I
cook anyone can code nine time tomorrow
but project manager me by discarding
school was set up by better hand se who
like Ida started coding at a very young
age on my ninth birthday I asked my
father for some money and he wouldn't
give it to me we made a deal that if I
made any money on the computer that we
had I'll be able to use it to celebrate
my birthday I would pitch my services
which were basically editing their
videos and storing some apps on their
phones I made about $90 that day so I
figured okay this is what I need to do
so that's when I first started coding
another more scratch I'm gonna scratch
battle hem is just 20 years old but it
already has a clear vision for the
future of Ethiopia's tech scene
artificial intelligence blockchain and a
lot of other things are happening around
the world this also will happen to us
eventually so we need to be ready more
than ever this generation needs to learn
how to be smarter than the machines
they're using but also have the skills
to really be in the job market in the
next five to ten years
not everyone can code however to prosper
Africa needs to create for your kinds of
jobs
[Music]
at the Eastern industry zone outside
addis ababa thousands of Ethiopians are
arriving for their chefs
the manufacturing park was built by a
Chinese firm to house factories making
textiles and shoes Ethiopia's
manufacturing industry is a success
story the value of its textiles and
clothes exports tripled over the past 10
years
and whereas manufacturing share of GDP
is shrinking in much of the rich world
in sub-saharan Africa has been growing
since 2011 yet for all the positives the
path to prosperity has potholes
productivity is lower and exports are
growing more slowly than expected
employee turnover is high what's more
covert 19 has men the borders have
slumped in the past few weeks
Ethiopia is unusual in Africa for its
focus on rapid industrialization across
the rest of the continent there's been
an expansion into what are known as
industries without smokestacks sectors
such as tourism IT and flour family it's
picking time Ethiopia's Highlands Laura
Rose farm under the watchful eye of fur
manager and abet Tesfaye federal butter
Tara wood every day 80,000 stems are
harvested from the farms 31 vast
greenhouses to be exported all over the
world the flower industry is new for
Ethiopia it's really a challenging
business because we compete with other
countries to grow the quality you have
to keep the start the international
standard this is exported commodity it's
helped us for the country for foreign
exchange Ethiopia's horticultural
industry employs 180,000 people it's
Africa's second largest flower exporter
after Kenya Emma Beth's farm employs
almost 500 local workers most are
unskilled laborers who are trained on
the job I think it's good for the
community
because if the industry is nearby to
them I think they get access to come and
to work otherwise it will be really very
difficult for the workers just to live
and survive to help create jobs for
their growing populations African
governments are faced with the decision
Lila so spider made Victor some think
the quickest path out of poverty is to
copy China to industrialize rapidly
giving workers jobs and factories others
reason the since China already dominates
manufacturing the best bet is to do
something else some see opportunities
and services such as IT and industries
without smokestacks such as horticulture
regardless of the route Africans take
they need to invest in technology Emma
bets farm is run by a computerised
system controlling temperature sunlight
and irrigation
how many waters would be perfect
in total per hectare is around 40 with
EQ this is smart agriculture ideas like
this need to spread more than half of
Africans make their living from farming
it's highly unproductive
although most Africans farm they
generate just 15 percent of Africa's GDP
that's because the way many people farm
has not changed much for hundreds of
years
modernizing farming could increase
yields to help feed rising populations
it would free lots of farm workers to go
and find better paid jobs in the cities
for one of the biggest obstacles to
successful agriculture or indeed other
industries is Africa's poor
infrastructure including its power
supply in a compound outside Addis Ababa
Machado is showing off her public shower
rotini a magazine Tunisia interrogators
would eat or dinner concerned animal
system what is the first radish Ethiopia
like many African countries is beset by
chronic electricity shortages
the bisciotti has found a way to keep
her business running by using power from
the Sun until the day it's too hard you
know the solar-powered water heater was
a gift from ass affirming Geshe the boss
of one of Ethiopia's first companies to
manufacture them people started coming
to take sure they start coming from
three towns around this area because
there is no public shower in all of them
people come in pain especially from
thirsty up to Sunday she's busy she made
a lot of money it makes money from the
Sun as Affairs business also shows one
way that Africa can help curb a global
threat climate change Africa emits just
2 percent of global greenhouse gases but
some experts predict it will be the
continent that suffers the most from
climate change Ethiopia is a growing
economy when if a starts developing
games
establishes many industries then she
needs industry energy Ethiopia has ample
sunshine
so why don't we take advantage of this
the Ethiopian government is spending
billions of dollars building a giant dam
on the Blue Nile River to generate
hydropower the ossifer is struggling to
get investment into his business and is
frustrated by bureaucracy Ethiopia is
more readable
especially in the last four or five
years government organization talked
about in terms of practice I don't know
how far it went
ultimately the key to addressing
Africa's problems is better governance
many countries have terrible
infrastructure rampant corruption
obstructed officials and occasional
armed revolts but Africans have more
political choices than before in the
1980s most African countries were
autocracies thirty years later most have
become substantially more democratic in
2018 a br mads became Prime Minister of
Ethiopia we promised democracy infuse
his work won him the Nobel Peace Prize
yet what all this points to a more open
Ethiopia the country could still be torn
apart by ethnic uprisings you can read
more about this by clicking on the eye
Ethiopia is one of many countries in
Africa that are making encouraging
progress in the short term the continent
may be severely damaged by covet 19 but
in the long term there are good reasons
to be optimistic more girls are going to
school economies are growing and
countries are adapting to climate change
but to match China's economic success
Africa can't just copy China
it needs more competent and accountable
governments that provide basic services
uphold the rule of law and educate their
growing populations if it does the next
century could yet be African century
you agree more of the economist
reporting on Africa by clicking on the
link opposite that will take you to the
special report of Africa's future as
well as our ongoing coverage on Africa
and covered 19 don't forget to like us
subscribe to our Channel and thanks so
much for watching
[Music]